[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants mon petit doigt me
dit qu'aujourd'hui vous avez été très
agitée est ce que c'est vrai voyons
comment ça se fait que pas trop sur le
1er avril
c'est le 1er avril oui mais alors vous
avez fait des blagues
moi en tout cas on m'en fait pas des
blagues en nombre au nom on m'en fait
pas des blagues
parce que j'ai l'air sérieux et bien
nous allons voir cela est bon
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants qu'est ce que ça va
être bon au honduras mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ce sera le premier league en
[Musique]
tic octobre
lui le petit coquin
[Musique]
non alors non pas moi un bon poisson
d'avril à un p'tit louis au delà voilà
ou alors que chercher à faire alors mais
bon bon bon bon bon puisque c'est comme
ça alors à mirabel oiseaux bavards
on veut qu'elle compte encore mais je ne
veux pas que ce point cela moi peu en
âge mais j'en ai assez à la fin de ce
poisson au revoir alors non ko puisque
c'est comme ça je vais la porter à
ulysse a aisni voulait à ulysse le bien
aussi il aura son poisson d'avril
on n'a jamais autant bien sûr
j'arrive pas trop à nous donc mais vite
de nuit petit force
un nouvelle fois son mari
[Musique]
on est petit louis monier mirabel bonne
nuit les petits enfants en temps mais
vous vite
c'était une belle journée on a fait
beaucoup de blagues
on a ri
et maintenant on va vite au lit alors
bonjour tu te dépêches je ris al wallon
route mon vieux nounours et à demain
augmente
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bonsoir j'ai bien
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui petit louis
et mirabel jouent aux marchands et à la
marchande bilan gros ours ont tu devrais
bien descendre m'acheter un kg de sable
fin sans faute patron un peu de chocolat
aussi non non non non non non ce n'est
pas la peine ou tout petit peu seulement
encore un peu de confiture pour le
monsieur oui même type en s'il vous
plaît madame vous voulez de la falaise
va se créer au boss kannemeyer va aux
fraises bien octobre je vais m'occuper
de vous de suite
il savait combien madame mirabel ça fait
différent monsieur voilà madame revel
merci et moi madame je voudrais 1 kg de
chocolat et du bon hein monsieur il est
excellent merci madame l'épicière waza
attend des offres en france où il est
dur ce chocolat ou à la marche 1
[Musique]
j'ai oublié prendre du café aussi un
oeuf à la coque voilà monsieur le
meilleur café
merci et un love coco voulait pas d
orange j'en ai deux belles bien rouge au
pas lent mais tu es mon 3 kg 3
olalala bébé mais il est vraiment dure
ce qu'on me donne et madame merci bien
plus d'hommes où je te met d'emblée trop
dur ce chocolat je me suis tu as c'est
tout bête d'enrôlement cesse au chocolat
qui est trop dur je me suis fait mal aux
dents ou un avis de roseaux c'était pas
du vrai chocolat et valait pas
tu m'as la marche oh le petit coquin
vous m'avez encore fait une drôle de
blague au temps des coachs vous attrape
à la maison attendez que je vous attrape
vous avez bien raison la prochaine fois
je ferai attention
bonne nuit petit coquin
[Musique]
pauvre gros ours
il est tellement gourmand qu'il n'a même
pas regardé si c'était du vrai chocolat
vous le voyez les gourmands sont
toujours attraper
alors gros source
tu as oublié ma commission ou monthieu
patron j'ai oublié mais mais demain j'y
penserai bon allons en route
bonnet les petits enfants faites de
beaux rêves
à demain 1 demain
[Musique]
bonsoir les petits enfants vous faut que
le petit enfant allons à l'ombre aux
sources pour dépêche toi d'aller voir
petit louis et mirabel nous avons encore
une très longue tournée à faire ce soir
patron je me dépêche et ce soir je
n'oublierai pas votre commission rock
promis juré et fait attention de ne pas
être trop gourmand - ce serait un gros
big up pour la tiba messieurs s'il vous
plaît un gros pour moi et trois petits
pots mais enfin ils sont petits veaux
enfin oui messieurs très petits au bol
en suisse on qui on va leur faire des
petits bifteck bientôt oui messieurs
s'il vous plaît bien bonjour monsieur le
marchand au beau vieux monsieur bonjour
voilà madame mirabel merci messieurs le
toucher et qu'est ce que je vous des
coupes monsieur gros saumons rouges y
ont donc en ton nom
ce soir je ne ferai rien pour moi mais
tu lis ma charge et d'une commission
weight attentes et je les écris sur un
petit bout de papier ne pourrai pas
l'oublier nous a surtout pas du chocolat
le voilà à lyon voit lyon 1 1 kg de
sable fin et pour ulysse
[Musique]
c'est un masque et l'argent de sable il
a besoin de beaucoup de sable car lui en
faut pour tous les petits enfants et le
soir quand il est l'heure d'aller au
dodo leur envoie quelques grains dans
les yeux des enfants et ceux ci ferme
vie que leurs yeux et s'endorment tout
de suite il faut que je m'engage
sinon lys va de nouveau mme grau des au
revoir les enfants au revoir je vais
regarder un petit peu si ce sable et
bien fait
[Musique]
bonne humeur belle boni petit louis dans
mes vite les petits enfants vous voilà
pas trop vous ai apporté votre sobre
merci nounours tu es très gentil mais tu
en as mis du temps j'ai bien
l'impression que tu ne va pas tarder à
dormir toi aussi allons en route
à demain bonne nuit
[Musique]
oh
ouf la nous voilà tout de même arriver
nous avions très peur d'être en retard
aujourd'hui car nous avions encore
beaucoup d'autres petits enfants à voir
avant vous mais fort heureusement les
vendeuses ont été très favorables
avez vous été très sage aujourd'hui
oui et j'en suis très content petit
louis et sa soeur mirabel ont eux aussi
étaient très mignons et pour les
récompenser gros ours leur a préparé un
joli jeu jeu très amusant je peux y
aller patron tu peux y aller nounours
études et embrassera bien fort de ma
part je comptais sur moi patrons eux hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop au jour les
gentils dit il dit honnêtement kachkar
ou bien je perds chez go non je vous ai
préparé un autre jeu beaucoup plus
amusant ah ah voilà mon mouchoir rouge
pâle rhume
on va jouer à colin maillard les enfants
commençaient
c'est drôle et pour sûr c'est drôle on
se cache les yeux avec le mouchoir qu'on
attache way et il faut essayer
d'attraper les autres attendez c'est pas
tout quand on attrape quelqu'un il faut
le reconnaître sans le regarder mais
seulement en le touchant à l'aide du
chat oui oui j'ai compris via lattea
louis approche tout va bien pour bon bon
bon
qui c'est qui commence c'est toi le nous
mais si tu vas mettre le foulard la rue
au 2 août ou l'âge et ouvre ses
attentions
l'egypte annonce non cash aux couleurs
pour la là où où la loi
j'ai la tête qui tourne h est parfait le
gie voit rien rien rien
un bel attrapé
non c'est une chaîne où passe cette fois
je peux tu heureux qui sait où qu où ça
pique
mais c'est un ballet cette fois c'est
parti je les attrape des coquins
[Musique]
alors les enfants le jeu vous a plu ah
voilà nounours qui revient je laisse à
cette fois ils ne peuvent pas aller plus
loin un faux plat
j'obtiens un voyons voir lequel s'est
pas petit louis ce pas non plus mirabel
mais qui c'est on sait ulysse le
marchand de sable à l'on enlève ton
bandeau se voue pas trop oui et il tombe
bien attrapé mon pauvre nigaud oslo oui
je suis un gros nigaud vous pouvez le
dire
alors en route nigauds
bonne nuit les enfants allez vite vous
coucher à demain à thomas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
bonsoir les enfants nous avons eu une
rude journée aujourd'hui nous sommes
allés à la télévision chercher toutes
les lettres que vous nous avez écrite et
notre nuage est bien chargé
gros ours s'est transformé en facteur
pour la circonstance je veux moi le
facteur patron g20 oui
vas-y le nours bon je prends mon sac où
aucune course ce sera cool la rue des
auques l'or et ferai attention de ne pas
tomber
monsieur le facteur pas de risque pas
trop j'ai le pied marin
[Musique]
moi je t'attrape et non c'est moi qui
vais t'attraper d'eau ou d'un ou deux
ans qu'est ce que c'est c'est l'acteur
oh là là là je suis tombée encore tomber
olala ça c'est lé facteur suite au plus
maladroit que la faute de toutes ces
lettres que je vous apporte les autres
lourdeurs 6,12 à fond notre 12e 12 à
saint lô
l'a1 et des mois les enfants ont posé le
sac
aller au bout attention on ouvre de sa
cage la voilà mes lunettes
non mais bon il y en a aussi pour ulysse
et pour moi voyons voir ce en voici une
belle adressées at il oui et un mihrab
cher merabet d'abord cher petit louis je
suis très mécontente des bêtises que
vous faites à nounours j'aime beaucoup
gros ours et j'espère que vous ne
recommencerez plus signé béatrice quelle
charmante en fait notre noble la nounou
non celle là elle est pour ulysse est là
ça c'est un très beau dessin mais il ya
aussi une lettre cher petit ours à aubes
alors je m'appelle brigitte et je t'aime
beaucoup
tu es très drôle quand tu agis tu t'es
grosse patte hood
oui patron ça c'est un télégramme à
urgent stop il faut aller au dodo stop
unissent d'accord alors les enfants
allez vous coucher sagement toussaint je
vous laisse les lettres vous pourrez les
lire demain au revoir il faut que je me
trouve par l'islam crocs dès l'été paris
va aller au moral ans à l'école toi vite
[Musique]
bonnet petit louis
bonnet mirabel bonne nuit tous les
petits enfants embrasser bien fort vos
parents est allé sagement vous coucher
alors notre facteur la tournée est
terminée ou non patron faut que je me
dépêche
j'ai beaucoup de lettres attribuées et
bien en route
connus des enfants
nous viendrons vous voir dimanche soir
bonne nuit
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir mes amis quel beau dimanche
aujourd'hui avec gros ours
on a fait la grasse matinée et ensuite
nous sommes allés à la campagne comme le
rappelle petit louis comme eux et comme
beaucoup d'autres enfants aussi et nous
sommes bien amusés
oloron on a bien rigolé le patron lors
on offre un bon repas décent vite voir
nos deux petits amis car ils sont
revenus très tôt de la campagne
spécialement pour nous voir j'y fonce
pas trop au plan propos pour vos propos
regarde comme elle est belle cette feria
fermiers bémol dans la maison c'est vrai
oui elle fait la soupe fait la soupe aux
lentilles passion et c'est là qu'en fait
je sais il y avait tout plein de fleurs
oui c'est vrai et on en a ramené que sur
celles à faire des affaires
on est allé chercher du lait tu vois il
y avait plein de petits cochons
comme celui-là il mangeait tout dans une
grande montjoire et il y avait aussi des
sons ma foi très mignon et puis et puis
et puis il y avait des vaches dans
l'écurie
et puis ça qu'est ce que c'est mais
marche très bien ce monologue et et
c'est vous qui l'avez fait bien sûr je
suis sûr qu'on peut faire de la vraie la
ville avec ta yo yo poteau c'est vrai je
suis un gros nigaud ulysse n'arrête pas
de me le répéter
moi je vois deux enfants qui ont
semaines et qui sont bien fatigués par
leur journée à la campagne
un halo ou dodo
[Musique]
plus
là j'éteins la lumière voilà bonne nuit
les petits
[Musique]
je le rappelle
non
[Musique]
mirabel et son frère petit louis dorment
déjà
à force de semer du sable j'ai bien
sommeil moi aussi le mot voilà patron
allons monsieur les nigauds en route
allons nous coucher nous aussi fou que
ça me fait trop bon repas pas trop au
oui bonne nuit des enfants faites de
beaux rêves
à demain demain
[Musique]
oh
bonsoir les enfants je ne sais pas ce
qui se passe mais il n'y a pas de bruit
dû toucher petit louis et mirabel et ça
sent très fort la pharmacie il faut que
je descende voir ce qui se passe ne fait
surtout pas de bruit nounou rue
peut-être bien qu'ils sont déjà couchés
va donc voir
soyez tranquilles patron je descends sur
la pointe des pâtes
[Musique]
bonjour me rebelles mais où est-il oui
pourquoi petit louis matte
mais qu'est-ce qu'il a les oreillons
[Musique]
nous voilà nous voilà nous voilà je suis
là que vit son bar amara simba latine
balade chemins se croisent arrive un peu
trop tard homme malade chez humala tu
m'as la trouble qu'est ce que c'est que
ce genre d'être malade maintenant 1
allons allons allons mais ne pleure pas
petite nuit ça ne fait pas mal les
oreillons quoi qu'il en soit huawei et
ça qu'est ce que c'est c'est un très
beau médicaments qui lui ne veut pas
boire c'est très mauvais c'est vraiment
très mauvaise foi lyon tu
oui c'est mauvais à boire mais si tu
veux être vite guéri et ne plus avoir
bobo à des petites oreilles
il faut que tu ne boivent entièrement
noircie murat belle donne moi le vert
voire la mort sic regarde maintenant tu
fermes les yeux et tu avales toutou dans
seul coup comme ça là là aller à toi
maintenant perdre des yeux
[Musique]
allez hop
si oui il ne faut pas toucher à ton
écharpe et comme il faut avoir très
chaud tu vas mettre celle là en plus je
transpire ce qu'il faut mais cette
bouille attend plus comme ça qui va
guérir ou tu sais vraiment heureux et si
tu prends bien tes médicaments et si tu
es très sage
demain je te raconterai une belle belle
belle histoire
blanche neige et les sept nains
oui on verra les enfants on verra alors
et elle évite la lumière et dormait vite
bonne nuit vincent source
à demain nos noces
couvre très bien petit louis om révèle
une nuit
[Musique]
moi
pauvre petit louis qui a attrapé les
oreillons mais ce n'est rien les
oreillons ce n'est pas grave
surtout quand on est sage je comprends
bien ce médicament tu as déjà eu les
oreilles ombre aux ours - coraux non
patron vient tu les auras peut-être
bientôt ne parle pas de malheur patron
bonne nuit des enfants embrasser bien
fort vos parents et aller vite au lit
demain votre ami sera presque guérie et
gros ours lui racontera une belle
histoire
bonne nuit à demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir mes chers petits amis vous savez
que p'tit louis et mirabel sont ma foi
de plus en plus sage
j'espère que vous aussi des petits
enfants qui m'écoutait vous faites
plaisir à vos parents d'accord gros ours
mais je t'en prie ne me fais pas trop
attendre soyez sans crainte patron au
plan pour propre compte
[Musique]
soir maisons font du voile annonce j'ai
pu tout mon médicament tout seul oh
c'est très bien petit louis tu es
vraiment un homme tu viendras continue
mais bien sûr les enfants
une très jolie histoire que m'a raconté
mon papa c'est l'histoire de la petite
améthyste et de la balançoire vous la
connaissez voilà y avait une fois il ya
bien longtemps
une petite fille qui s'appelait un métis
pourquoi me disent tu parce qu'elle
avait de grands yeux tout bleu couleur
d'une jolie pierre précieuse qu'on
appelle améthyste
elle vivait dans une grande forêt avec
ses parents et avec les amis de ses
parents
les animaux ils habitaient dans des
maisons de paille
le papa de la petite améthyste partait
tôt le matin travaillé dans la forêt sa
maman allait faire les commissions et
améthyste jouait tout seul dans la
grande forêt elle n'avait pas peur moi
vous l'avez vous avait toujours peur
bien sûr que non tous ses amis jouaient
avec elle
de jolis oiseaux de toutes les couleurs
et elle jouait aussi à cache cache avec
les biches et les chevaux remises aux
ministres jaillit ils étaient tous très
gentils avec elle
sauf un vilain serpent un gros tigre et
cet énorme crocodile qui aurait bien
voulu la manger c'est pas gentil
on en sait peu gentil du taudis dans les
barreaux d'améthyste lui avait bien
recommandé de faire attention mais un
jour qu'elle était parti trop loin dans
la forêt elle rencontra le gros
crocodile la bouche ouverte
tout près à la manger quand tout à coup
un bar à 800 l'enleva dans l'ère larrat
chante ainsi autant du vilain crocodiles
c'était un gros singe qu'il avait ainsi
sauvé il avait posé dans un arbre sur
une branche qui bougeait se balançaient
améthyste trouvais cela très amusant
c'était la première fois qu'elle se
balance et elle rien elle rien fait à
présent de se balancer vrai mais ses
parents étaient rentrés à la maison et
l'a cherché partout il s'était trouvé et
l'on trouve un bronze ou le vide à man u
l'entend dire qu'ils riaient et levant
la tête il à vire dans l'arbre en train
de se balancer avec le gros singe ils
furent très heureux de voir qu'elle
avait inventé un jeu nouveau très drôle
qu'on appelle maintenant la balançoire
c'est être à bout tu sais
[Musique]
le
non
bonnet petit louis bony mirabel bonne
nuit tous mes chers petits amis
embrassez vos parents allaient vite au
dodo et en dormez vous bien sagement
nous reviendrons vous voir sans faute de
main
bonne nuit à demain à te voilà nounours
allons en route
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour les amis
nous sommes très contents aujourd'hui
petit louis est guéri gros ours descend
vite le voir à tout à leurs patrons eux
pu alors pourquoi mais ne tarde pas trop
à revenir au repos bonbons aux brotteaux
le japon
alors comment se porte le monsieur aux
régions pauvres
j'ai préparé un beau bébé
je ne sais pas si rose bonbon
[Musique]
ce que j'ai fait il ya bien les mêmes
bien bas et qu'est ce qu'il y a de bon
vin chaud il y à du chocolat chaud
[Musique]
mais attention il ya aussi des gâteaux
des brillants lol lol la mena non au pot
ce boss chocolat maaf et oui même si je
prends une brioche mais certains oui oui
mais je voudrais rappeler la ta sera le
[Musique]
bon c'est vraiment délicieux mets ta
servières que tu es s'annonce t plaque
sera partout maintenant
maintenant je continue
nous aurons c'est trop bon gros bon sens
moi j'ai plus à chalon qui mangent et
gâteaux
ah oui alors qu' à manger le gâteau
c'est pour moi un tout petit peu
seulement tu peux te cacher ma ville
ça c'est pas bon on m'aurait bien manger
moi aussi j'ai fait rien ne nous feront
la prochaine fois je te ferai quelque
chose de meilleur encore des spaghettis
[Musique]
lecomte mal au coeur c'est fait ouais
les courbes en sont toujours punis
allons les enfants aller vite au dodo
moi il faut que je me sauve ylisma temps
au revoir
[Musique]
halloween qui coiffe
ouais
demain les petits enfants mais ne soyez
jamais aussi gourmand que peut-il oui
car vous risqueriez d'être malade ou
ceux de bon ce tabou et oui oui c'était
bon mais suite à moustache on tu as
l'air malin avec cette serviette de pb
vous tombez autres tous allomusic patron
way
bogny mirebel boni petit louis bony les
enfants aller vite au lit et faites de
beaux rêves
à demain
oh
[Musique]
bonsoir les amis aujourd'hui vous savez
mirabel et p'tit louis ont été vilain
gouy vilain ils n'ont pas voulu manger
leur soupe rue qui était ma foi très
bonne chose
grosos l'aurait bien manger nuit ou la
wii
moi j'aime bien la soupe je descends les
voir patron oui vas-y nounours mais rien
qu'un tout petit moment où nous prenons
en plus au plein d'un corps retrouve bon
jour les enfants
un bien les enfants mon petit doigt me
dit quelque chose
moi je mange la moitié de ma souvenance
alors mirabel cuillé taratata ne me
raconte pas des blagues
tu n'as rien manger du tout petit
mirabel ce n'est pas gentil mourrions le
titre est bonne c'est sous et moi je
l'aurais bien manger je ne vais pas bien
vous savez il y a beaucoup de petits
enfants qui ont faim faim faim et qui
seraient très contents d'avoir une bonne
soupe comme ça c'est vrai je pense bien
que c'est vrai et bien la prochaine fois
je la mange raismes à soupe
moi aussi c'est très bien et maintenant
au dodo à l'eau aux plats
[Musique]
non non ce qui nous raconte une petite
histoire oui à tout petit bon alors une
jolie devinettes
elles sont très gros si elle voyage dans
le ciel les jours de pâques
elle apporte quelques fois une surprise
aux garçons et aux filles qui sont sages
qui mangent bien leur soupe et elles
font du bon donc
et oui mais comment le savez-vous parce
que dans quelques jours c'est pas et
nous partirons en vacances et la
campagne et les clubs ils apporteront
des yeux tout un chocolat chocolat
oui bien peut-être bien oui oui on va
sûrement un petit moment
c'est possible oh moi je rappe où ça et
moi aussi
en pianotant chocolat mois-ci et moi
aussi j'espère que les cloches ne
l'oublierons pas
[Musique]
nikos a du mal oui les enfants à demain
bonne nuit
bonne nuit mirabel
[Musique]
mais oui c'est vrai c'est bientôt pâques
et les cloches vont passer dans le ciel
en faisant donc du dong dong et si vous
êtes bien sage elle vous apporteront une
petite surprise
et vous partirez peut-être aussi en
vacances à la campagne comme petit louis
et mirabel alors soyez bien sage
nous verrons vous voir demain bonne nuit
les enfants aller vite au dodo et
embrasser bien fort vos parents bonne
nuit brune nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les amis aujourd'hui vous savez
mirabel et p'tit louis ont été vilain
oui vilain ils n'ont pas voulu manger
leur soupe rue qui était ma foi très
bonnes aux grosses l'aurait bien manger
nuit ou la wii
moi j'aime bien la soupe aux jeux 200
les voir patron oui vas-y nounours mais
rien qu'un tout petit moment rouge pour
longtemps eu au plein d'un corps bonjour
mes enfants elle bien les enfants
mon petit doigt me dit quelque chose
moi je mangeais la moitié de ma souvent
alors mirabel cuillé taratata ne me
raconte pas des blagues
tu n'as rien manger du tout petit
mirabel ce n'est pas gentil mourrions le
thé très bonne cette soupe et moi je
l'aurais bien rangé je vais pas bien
vous savez il y a beaucoup de petits
enfants qui ont faim faim faim et qui
seraient très contents d'avoir une bonne
soupe comme ça je pense bien que c'est
vrai et bien la prochaine fois je la
mange raismes à soupe
moi aussi c'est très bien et maintenant
au dodo
alors hop là
[Musique]
non ce qui nous raconte une petite
histoire que d'un tout petit bon alors
une jolie devinettes
elles sont très gros si elle voyage dans
le ciel les jours de pâques
elle apporte quelques fois une surprise
aux garçons et aux filles qui sont sages
qui mangent bien leur soupe et elles
font du bon donc oui mais mais comment
le savez-vous
parce que dans quelques je sais pas et
nous partirons à relancer la campagne et
les clubs qu'ils apporteront des lieux
tout en chocolat chocolat bien peut-être
bien oui oui on va sûrement un petit
poucet nomura
c'est possible au moins je rap ou 5 et
moi aussi
empire notre chocolat mois-ci et moi
aussi j'espère que les cloches ne
l'oublierons pas oui les enfants à
demain bonne nuit
bonne nuit ni mirabel
[Musique]
mais oui c'est vrai c'est bientôt pâques
et les cloches vont passer dans le ciel
en faisant donc dû ding dong
et si vous êtes bien sage elle vous
apporteront une petite surprise
et vous partirez peut-être aussi en
vacances à la campagne comme petit louis
et mirabel alors soyez bien sage
nous verrons vous voir demain bonne nuit
les enfants aller vite au dodo et
embrasser bien fort vos parents bogny
produits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir des enfants soit ce soir nous
venons vous dire au revoir car nous
partons pour notre nouveau voyage oui
groso c'est bien triste de vous quitter
moi aussi au saint-louis patron mais
vous le savez nous reviendrons le plus
vite possible vous retrouver et nous
aurons des tas de belle histoire à vous
raconter alors je veux un patron oui
descend vite nounours et en bracelet
bien fort de ma part oui
la jemaye encore des mouchoirs et ma
poupée préférée
bonsoir les petits voyageurs sa maman
comment vous faites encore vos bagages
cette fois c'est fini on a tout préparé
pour notre départ demain matin et vous
dénonce vous n'avez rien oublié ta porte
et en ajoie
oui oui on est et reste un bon tu sais
on viendra bientôt tienne nous
transporte supportons voyage est très
gros pot de miel ne mangent pas tous le
premier jour où des enfants j'en
mangerais une seule cuillère chaque jour
et comme sa passerelle
oui c'est promis merci le cher petit ami
7 vous reviendrai dans un mois chicana
vacances vous n'oublierez pas d'emmener
le petit poussin avec vous ah non on
mettra avec une maman poule il y aura
bien chaud il s'amusera avec d'autres
pistes ouais ouais j'ai envie à l'eau
les enfants au dodo d'ulysse m'appelle
ben ainslie
[Musique]
ou bien grosses joues tu sais on a pris
une belle chanson pour toi et pour
ulysse parce que nous vous aimons
beaucoup beaucoup
oui beaucoup comme ça moi c'est la fin
de la journée c'est le moment de se
coucher la zone paul non
amis ils s'en vont tous sont liés nous y
allons aussi demander lise je n'en sais
rien au jeu l'entente qui lie
ni nous dira fermez vos yeux et d'amis
tous les deux nous sommes bien dans
notre lit sauf nous fouette à bonanni sa
brosse mois le feu
au plaisir elle avait dit au revoir mes
deux petits amis au revoir votre chanson
est très belle
mon voyage à bientôt nounours à bientôt
les enfants
[Musique]
au revoir petit louis au revoir petite
mirabelle passer de belles vacances et
soyez bien gentil n'oubliez pas d'aller
vous coucher sagement chaque soir et
nous reviendrons bientôt vous voir
allons allons ne sois pas triste
nounours car les petits enfants savent
bien qu'on reviendra vite ils ne sont
pas tristes d'un corps patron buzz les
aime beaucoup et subtil tout était en
ordre pour le voyage
oui patron tout alors en route roux au
revoir tous nos amis et à bientôt
bonne nuit
[Musique]
où
oh
[Musique]
où